next to him trunks on his left
she puts a hand in that position as well
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below
you can also use the discount code
salaam 10
for 10 of their products assalamu
alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another video first i want to
praise allah the most merciful the most
trust or praise is glory
and gratitude belong to him um so
basically i've got sent this video now i
don't really know
chunks i don't know him much i don't
know i i i heard that he done a rap
video
look i don't know much about him i'll be
honest with you guys i genuinely don't
know much about him
at all i know brother smather just done
a video about him a couple of months ago
that's it i don't know much about him
but when i was watching this video
which was sent to me just have a look i
randomly came across this part in the
video and i found it quite interesting
and i thought there was a lot of lessons
to be learned because at the end of the
day a lot of people
uh maybe the industry chunk the chunks
um is involved in
we can't say per say it's it's it's
quite um
halal uh you know uh be the free mixing
or
many elements that we can list but
something caught my attention so let's
watch this video let's react to it it's
not that long
yeah okay guys the next one is going to
be meat and fish now meat and fish is my
speciality this is the pizza this is
what i'm gonna give you about there go
on okay you guys ready come here
i'm just worried please please
did you guys catch that so he said
alhamdulillah
yeah uh now we're going to come to why
a lot of you guys might watch this and
like okay just a phraseology you know
just used to it etc
um not really but let's let's let's
carry on let's currently don't forget so
the first thing that was
uh we saw there was um something
revealed and him saying alhamdulillah
yeah okay so let's carry on
that's my favorite first things first of
all i never knew that they have these
things in africa
african snail ah
i'm here yeah we're gonna chill back
things are getting why
last time it was gizzard now it's
african snail that's what you
so my ingredients are butternut squash
sorry darkish head top
that's it red chicha chorizo that's a
pokemon um african snail what's going to
bring out the big
pop snails
white rice and birds actually right
white rice with snails don't be like
that
on my on my episodes so that's prayer
that's what i've done
[Music]
that was amazing that's amazing amazing
okay so now
when i'm watching this because usually
my wife has the same app
that has the same event so i was
watching um i was listening to in the
car
and when i went off it was her phone
then i realized when they had the
reaction
as you can see putting their hands there
um and the guests and you can hear what
the guest says that there says actually
that's amazing
uh even the female next to him trunks on
his left she puts a hand in that
position as well
but harry before we get so now there's a
few things i want to touch upon because
it's very important now
i i don't like i said before i don't
know chunks i don't know much about him
i don't know
what he does um but i'm sure like
all of us or maybe no he's an influencer
maybe he does things that are not
permissible yeah
like i said if i don't know much maybe
there's rap etc
there's a certain swear word that he
uses etc i'm not trying to be nitpicking
here and there's certain things that
he's doing et cetera even free mixing
there because i don't think we need to
be honest here
if that was a hijabi sister um and there
was a um
a male there next to her and touching
him except touching her etc
we would all lose the plot and let's be
consistent here yeah because i didn't
date
male or female surprise talent doesn't
differentiate yeah when it comes to law
in the case and this video is not about
that per se okay i'm not here to
pinpoint on people's uh mistakes et
cetera and then they
people who do big mistakes and um
promote
haram outright to their followers yes
you know we tried to advise our brothers
etc and we wouldn't expect the same from
us
but this video was on a few reactions
number one him using the
uh the phrase alhamdulillah yes or
praise
then the event going off on his phone
yeah and then
he's saying that salah time you can see
the reaction that he had
on his guests and they're like wow
that's amazing yeah and then you see
even the sister next to may allah
subhanahu ta'ala guide her and
everyone as well they're putting their
hands together so they so they kind of
acknowledge and know
now a lot of the times brothers and
sisters a lot of us sin
we're all sinners and we like i sin as
well yeah maybe not publicly i try to
abstain from sinning publicly but this
doesn't necessarily that makes me better
than you
you know because there might be
something that you do that is more
beloved to allah than me that all the
dial work that i do
i don't even know if you'll be accepted
so the point is
this message and this video i'm doing is
for those out there who might be
involved in certain industries or might
be doing haram etc and they know it is
but they do not let go of their deen
this is very fundamental because the
shaytan comes and attacks you how
i've got the bokeh again yeah there was
deception you guys got to read that
there was deception
therefore the shaytan comes to you and
you know what his biggest tricks are you
know what's one of the biggest tricks
let me tell you is one of his biggest
tricks is what
to make you feel guilty yeah how does he
do that
you go clubbing and then after that what
would you come and say you've gone
clubbing now
and now you want to go and pray salah
now you want to go and do this and that
you went and committed a major sin you
committed a sinner yeah and now you want
to go and pray
you went and drank alcohol even though i
would say ah you're
the one who drinks alcohol there's salah
is not valid for 40 days just a lot more
even valid problems
no that's the deception of shaytan you
still need to pray
it means it's not valid but you still
need to pray
sister salah is something that is
indebted to allah if your
uh um landlord comes and asks for the
rent you're not gonna say i can't i
can't do it
i can't pay because of this no no you
have to pay the rent
you know salah is the right upon allah
so this is why it's very important
brothers and sisters if i'm not mistaken
he was traveling with the prophet peace
be upon him and he said the prophet
peace be upon him said omar do you know
what is the right
of the slave upon allah he said allah's
messenger knows best he said it is that
you worship him him and him alone
yeah and obviously doing the access et
cetera and then he said omar do you know
what is the
rights of of allah upon his servants
and he said what is it oh mr of allah
you and allah knows best
yeah he said is that as long as you
worship him alone
that he will not punish you so brothers
and sisters do not be deceived from the
shaytan
because even though trunks might be
living a lifestyle that is not per
islamically correct and there's things
that he does he should work on
hamdulillah we all should work on
the point here is this he does not the
word alhamdulillah for him to use that
anytime something what happens it's a
good
sign it's a good sign these little
things that you yourself might carry
don't let go of these don't think i'm a
sinner i shouldn't even use
alhamdulillah anymore this is the plot
of shaytan because
the more he moves you away from islam
the better if you can stop using
alhamdulillah what are you gonna use
instead of that oh thank god
oh thank you no use alhamdulillah that's
good because that al hamdulillah
that is in your subconscious mind one
day can click and bring you back
in the context so i'm not saying leaving
the father islam but it can bring you
closer alhamdulillah or praise belong
that is
and you're not worshiping any other than
that and and it's very very profound
there was a scholar i can't remember he
said it is more beloved
for somebody to lie while taken off by
allah
than to tell the truth by taking off by
other deities
i repeat again lying is a big thing and
the prophet sallam hated lies
and he said the believer is nothing
anything but a liar but here the
scholars trying to say something very
important saying
it is more beloved that somebody lies
saying i didn't taking off allah then
telling the truth and saying i swear by
um my cow god or i would be like jesus
or this that
that is more beloved than taken off by
other
uh false deities so you can see
that subhan allah is salah he's got for
him to have the evan
that means he's conscious of his salah
that even on the future that is that i'm
sure he didn't just you know put that
there for the sake of it
you know we assume the best in our
brother so you can see that his salah is
reminded and that is beautiful
because no matter what he might be doing
and the struggles that he's having up
and down and i'm sure he might be
watching this maybe
the fact that he's got his salah on
check them is that boom
time and that is so fundamental and this
goes for every single one of you guys
no matter what sin you do look whatever
sin you do
yes do not let go of your salah
do not i'm repeating it do not let go of
your salah
that is your building block when things
go sour that's what you're going to fall
upon
and that is where allah subhanallah says
it takes you keeps you away from fascia
from evil deeds etc and subhanallah and
i'm going to end with this verse
uh in sura 35 i'm not mistaken
and this is a direct verse that was that
came down where
female servants asked for something that
directly um
quotes them allah subhanallah says in
the quran and this is where allah
specifically addresses the male and the
female and listen carefully what does
that lost a panel
say
[Music]
for muslim men and muslim women believe
in men and believe in women
devote men and devote women true for men
and truth for women
patient men and patient women humble men
and humble women
charitable man and woman fasting men and
fasting woman
men and women who guard their chastity
and men and women who remember allah
often
for all of them allah has prepared
forgiveness and a great reward
brothers and sisters i want to end with
that verse and you can see
while we ask allah to make us amongst
those he's just mentioned here
and let's struggle and strive and let's
not give up no matter what sin you're
committing stick stick firm to the robe
of allah we are all sinners and the best
of sinners i've also repent
i hope this video can be sent to chunks
and he can watch it and benefit i don't
need him to give me a shout or anything
like that
i would just uh i just came across this
video and i just wanted to react to it
and benefit for all of you guys in shock
as well as him
till next time may allah bless you guys
inshallah let's not give up and may
allah unite every single one of us in
jannah
accept our deeds make us sincere and
that's your brother sisters do not
forget to like and subscribe inshallah
if you want
if you don't want to you don't have to
you better do till next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi
wabaraka